started with a quick recap where we are
today with containers and kubernetes and
Google container engine oh something
went wrong
well actually this isn't a real outage
luckily but for the software developers
in the room I have some good news for
you it's not usually your code that is
the main cause of outages it's actually
the way it's configured operated
deployed so operating software is
difficult we have all of these things to
think about so how do we deploy our
software how do we deal with continuous
integration how do we deal with scaling
how do we deal with monitoring without
fear how do our services discover each
other so that they can communicate well
let's see if containers have some of the
answers containers give us a consistent
portable packaging format so we have
somewhere where we can wrap up our
application code and our dependencies
together it's mutable it's Ameet
immutable it can be versioned we can
stash it in a container registry it's a
really handy artifact that makes it easy
to deploy and most importantly it can
run anywhere so docker has become the
de-facto container runtime and it will
run on pretty much any OS we get a
lightweight isolation which means we can
disentangle our application processes
from each other they won't stomp on each
other's application code and
dependencies libraries can be managed
independently application by application
and we can set restrictions on how much
CPU and memory each of our applications
get to stop them from competing with
each other and this is all really
lightweight so unlike a VM where you
might have a hypervisor and a guest OS
these restrictions are enforced by the
kernel which means they can start up and
stop really quickly and they're kind of
transient processes aside from any data
they might store and miss also we have a
standard control plane so no matter what
we're running and where were
we can stop it we can start it in the
same way we have hooks into monitoring
but does that get all the way there I
think we still have to think about all
of these things so which virtual machine
is out is our container going to run on
how are we going to replicate it for
fault tolerance how will we know if it's
healthy how will we handle incoming
network traffic load balancing things
like that how are we going to wire up
our applications so that they can speak
to each other and then is microservices
which means you know if you're
decomposing your monolith or your larger
service into lots of little services you
have all the more to think about and you
have all of these extra communication
paths that suddenly appear so you have
amazing complexities potentially to deal
with there well that takes us to Cuban
eighties and I think it has answers to
these questions for us so at its root
kubernetes allows us to schedule and run
containers on a fleet of physical
machines or virtual machines and it
allows us to cut the cord with the
physical world so we don't have to think
any more about where our applications
are running instead we can think about
things in terms of an application or
even a service centric view of the world
communities was initially developed
inside Google I think we first announced
it about three years ago and it went 1.0
about two years ago and at that time
when it went 1.0 over a quarter of the
code had come from outside of Google it
shows the larger community was involved
from the beginning and in subsequent
releases more than half of the code has
come from the wider community so I think
you can see that community and the
general software development community
and operations is now the power that's
driving forward the state-of-the-art
with this framework and the community is
enormous I think there was a tech
republic article a while ago that showed
that the communities community is
something like five times larger than
the nearest similar community so Google
has now seven apps I think which
operate with more than 1 billion active
users at Google we believe that running
applications in containers is the right
place to do it and we've been doing it
ourselves for 12 years and I think you
can think pretty much any one of those
services that serving those uses Maps
whatever is running running inside a
container now all of this at this story
with kubernetes doesn't mean that your
ops team is going to be out of the job
the Google ops team the core Ops teams
continue to grow but the number of
containers in our fleet has grown over
ten times faster so to tell us a bit
about kubernetes in the wild I'm really
excited to invite our friend from excite
to the stage so please give he go a
round of applause and he's going to tell
us hello guys thank you James thank you
all for coming
it's great to be here today to talk a
bit about excite Cuban AIDS and Google
cloud platform or if UI for starting
what we do at excite well excited
personalized music a television channel
you could see it as a Spotify on Netflix
for music videos and our application
which runs on top of all linear channel
and based on what or users decide like
keep skip or like on music we TP doing
indications for the recommendations on
real time and we have now more than 100
K music videos in your database and this
amount only grows each day yeah this is
how the application looks like on your
TV you can have different kind of
channels like just rock music yo you can
really personalize it and depending on
the actions like this is what looks like
on your TV one user likes a video
this is what it looks like when he or
she skips it of course you can watch
straight away on your TV and based on
the actions that the user just took all
algorithmic improves the video
recommendation on real time as you can
see now we are improving that channel so
it's it's actually a very cool thing to
run and to maintain and if you want to
to test that by yourself we invite you
all to go to Z go if you have channel
285 this is nice okay now let's go to
the cool part coolest when I first
started at excite I found this infra
running on premises and encoded video
Mac minis as you can imagine a lot of
things could go wrong there and it did
so we had all kind of outages like
crashing servers limited storage
capacity power electricity power
sometimes we had electric power or
building then we need to send the entire
music department home because they could
not work and of course one of the main
problems also the DS solution on
premises was not scalable at all if we
need to encode more videos then we need
to add more Mac minis and keep it
maintained nice so this was like not
good so the first thing that came to my
mind when I arrived was not inhale I
will keep the end of this we are going
to rebuild everything and about this new
platform that we would start
well I knew three things for sure about
it first of all it had to be cloudy
agnostic because at excite it's very
important for us to be sure that our
users they are being provided have been
provided with the best service possible
we can offer to them and we do believe
to be able to choose in which cloud
platform we are going to run our
solution it's an essential part on this
process so the platform the solution the
new one had to be cloudy agnostic and of
course open source community had to be
behind it because I do know we do know
how important the open source community
is for any project and great news James
just gave us that now more than 50% of
the kodi of cuba needs they came from
the community and another important fact
about this new platform was that I
wanted to be fast and efficient fast at
the point that we could reply all API
requests in like is more milliseconds
and efficient at the point that we can
encode the 4k videos cheap affordable
way
so after analyzed these three conditions
these three main conditions it was clear
that
turbinates would be a great choice for
us and we went for it okay after we
decide going for Cuban AIDS why to use
why to go for Google container engine if
you don't know Google container engine
is the Google solution for hosting
containers well so why why going for it
and not going to any other cloud
provider as you know cubanelles came
running in multiple different place well
the first reason why we decided going
for Google container engine engine was
the fact that it's already itself a
Cuban AIDS cluster which means the
container engine itself is already run
inside Cuba needs and this is a pretty
cool thing and also proves that the
technology works after that another
important point on choosing Google
container engine platform was the fact
that their Google key manager the Cuban
AIDS closer for the Cuban agent master
for you
and this saves a long amount of time we
said of be managing the master updated I
just let this job to Google and I keep
focused on making the cluster better and
this is like a huge huge advantage and
another thing that we went for Google
container engine is the cost benefit
they have all kind of discounts if you
keep the your server running for the
full month of the week sort of the days
of the month you get immediately a
sustaining use discount on your VM which
can be around 30% of its price so it's
actually a very good cost efficient so
we decide to 84 Cuban eight then Google
container engine and this was a good
choice so I will talk to you now how we
doing coding videos or Cuban AIDS and
Google container engine actually our
encoding process it's very efficient
every time we need to encode a new video
Cuba needs that support encoding part in
only preemptable vm 32 visibles and the
only job of this part is to encode that
assistive video when it's done cuban a
to you automatically destroy the part
and also the pre-emptive of VM if you
don't know what a pre-emptive eme is
well a good way to explain this is but
this is more like access of computing
resources resources on that it
specifically Google Data Center so
Google is not is not in use it at that
moment so Google offers you to have a VM
as a preemptable which means that this
VM is going to run up to 24 hours
however it can be destroyed by any time
by Google which is just 30 seconds not
see if this access of computing
resources is needed somewhere else in
the data center
however they can cost up to 80% cheaper
than a regular VM so it's actually a
good deal you can see a pre-emptive of
VM as a beautiful butterfly it's gonna
arrive to our life fast make it better
bright and suddenly this result so your
application also has to be able to
handle it in case of a resilient problem
happens because the pre-emptive machine
was destroyed however this works pretty
good for us and this is one proof of
that the integration between cuban AIDS
and Google cloud platform works great we
use Cuban eight node selector to define
which know the pool that specific pod
should start another pool it's a Google
containing compute engine officially its
allow you to deploy several different
group of machines that contain the same
hardware on it and it's a very nice
feature because in your case we can have
a node pool with 32 V CPUs preamp
volumes just for encoding pods there and
that on the same Cuban is cluster we can
have a different node pool with 4 CPUs
machine only for renewal API pod so this
integration is very powerful because you
can use the right pattern for the right
job and this in the end it saves money
another cool to think we use on Cuba
natives of course the Cuban 8 horizontal
pod out scaling this means that cuban
aids has the ability to increase and
decrease the number of pods
automatically when it's needed in all
case of api in the morning
less people using it so Cuba needs it's
automatically keeps the amount of pods
running at the minimum level however in
the afternoon the evening when we have
more people watching your channel more
traffic arriving Cuba needs can detect
it and automatically increase the amount
of pots so a platform is red for this
new bait arrived for this new traffic
and will key we can still keep it
replying in the prior as soon as Cuban s
realizes these resources is no more no
longer needed it will automatically
decrease your platform down so this also
saves money for you because you don't
need to run more resources than what is
really needed on that moment all the big
problem we had was about the storage and
the Google Nearline storage it really
solves all the problems we had it's a
great speed cost-benefit you can
retrieve data faster in like a round one
second cost is only 10 then around 10
euros per month for terabyte and this is
really midfield between a regular
storage and the disk a passion
straightaway to your machine because it
works fast we can we play some previews
of forecast video to all off see you
straight away from the storage when we
start
I didn't image this could be possible
but it was pretty good actually
so the main quest 1 million dollar
question was it all worth it yes it was
if your company is thinking about
migrating to Cuba nades you should start
it right now it has great benefits of
course a bit of work to get it done and
Google Google compute Google cloud
platform really helps you to deploy it
so now right now we have our main
applications running already
Kuban it's no longer and we need these
in-house infra thanks God and we can
call the machines with preemptable very
fast and efficient for us it's cheap
actually it's 15 times faster now the
encoding process than what it was in
house and the bread was makes it it's
really affordable and the near line is
storage on Google really fix all
problems related to a storage capacity
and of all electric Quixote's we don't
have anything of that and more of course
and the most important aspect
reliability we can trust we can rely
more on all soft that it's gonna work
because we have no longer hardware
issues or electrical electrical issues
or it works way better than before
what's next follows that excite well
exciting is growing very fast we're
going to be probably in 2 8 5 different
countries in the next 2 or 3 years so of
course I want to federate everything I
want my all my classes that I'm gonna
release on different zones around the
world to connect to integrate to put my
customers to talk to each other if you
need it and another thing that we are
missing a bit on cue business and I have
good news that we're gonna have before
in a bit from James it's a steel it's a
safe smash system that we're gonna need
it Matt talked about a bit more a bit
about it and I'm looking forward to
implement it it's important for us
attack site to keep using top
technologies and still I do believe is
the next new thing coming and this will
be a real game-changer for Cuban
explosives well if you have any question
this was it for me I will be around it
will be great to talk to you about
excite Cuban AIDS or anything on Google
cloud platform thank you very much for
coming
was it thank you guys they could do
thank you go so I know many of you
probably getting hungry and it's going
to get a little bit nerdy from this
point onwards so try to keep your brains
running for a little bit longer so let's
talk about using capacity efficiently
for a moment so many people in the room
might be familiar with the feeling of
having a few processors say running on a
VM or a few VMs and it doesn't feel
logical to put some other processes
there so you leave it like that but the
the VM is largely idling the Machine you
know it's not using all of the memory
and CPU available to it well the
kubernetes scheduler is really good at
playing Tetris I think that's a good way
to think about it it knows how to to
pack those containers into the available
capacity really efficiently but I've
heard it said that you could even
quadruple the effective capacity of your
data center in this way but for some
people that's not enough so let's talk
about how you could run a 5,000 node
cluster so maybe there's someone in the
room who would like to run a 5,000 node
cluster I definitely got colleagues
would be interested in talking to you
afterwards so if you ran a 5,000 node
cluster and you used our 64 core
machines which have launched quite
recently I think you would have 233
million 600,000 core hours per month and
you'd be paying about seven million
dollars a month for that but once the
sustained use discount kicked in I think
you'd get it down to under four million
dollars but obviously not everybody
wants to do that the good news though is
that because we operate clusters it
scales like that everyone benefits in
terms of latency so we have design
targets that our API is the community's
API should respond in under one second
and the pods should start up within five
seconds so
if you eat a mentioned Federation if you
if you wanted to have the ultimate high
availability solution you could run a
cluster in each region where you had
customers around the world and get them
to join in a club which is called a
Federation and get some sort of
centralized control over the components
in it and at the same time you could
have a single global load balancer in
front of it
which would automatically take care
browsing your clients requests to the
nearest healthy cluster in the world so
as your clusters grow and your
operations teams grow you probably need
to think about how you're going to
control access to all of these things
all your eggs could be in one basket now
otherwise so in the past here we have a
blue team and a green team if these
people had access to the cluster to
change things then that was it they
could do what they liked then Along Came
namespaces which gave us some form of
separation but not really enforced with
teeth so you could separate out your
concerns here but you you couldn't you
could just do things like say the blue
team will get a certain amount of CPU
and memory and the green team will get
the rest now with role based access
control that can be enforced so if you
have a user a group or a service account
and a resource that you want to control
access to and a resource doesn't just
have to be a namespace here we have that
as an example it could be a pod or it
could even be say read access to the
logs of that pod rights now you can have
a role which will play a part in
connecting those things together so a
role could be an out-of-the-box role so
cluster admin write the way down to
somebody a custom role of somebody who
could write or read a particular
resource or even a combination of
resources and you can connect them
together with a role binding giving you
that fine-grained access control another
thing is storage so earlier we talked
about disconnecting from the physical
world and just thinking about our
application and our service centric view
of the
unfortunately storage seems to take us
back to that physical world and people
may be familiar with the days when they
had to request storage say the server or
their cluster was running low and
panicking about the database causing it
to overflow and crash you you would
actually have to request storage maybe
someone would had to rack it more
recently someone might separately still
an ops team perhaps might provision it
with your cloud provider and then they
would attach it to to a node or a VM
which still doesn't quite fit in with
this this service centric view of the
world we've been talking about because
your pod might one day be running on one
node or VM and and the next day it might
be on another so for a while we've had
persistent volume claims which give you
a means of associating your storage
after you've provisioned it with with a
running pod wouldn't it be nice if we
could automate that well now we can do
that with dynamic provisioning so if a
pod starts up and it has a persistent
volume claim and it wants to have this
storage associated with it if it doesn't
already have access to the storage that
storage can just be created on the fly
and we also have something called
storage classes which is basically a
blueprint for a certain type of storage
you might have so different cloud
providers or some some SSDs yeah and you
can effectively give it a label and and
make an abstraction there so say the
SSDs your gold storage ooh your fast
storage so then all your system volume
claim has to do is say I want this kind
of storage and I want this amount of it
and it'll get sorted out so I think
we're back in the in the application
centric view of the world so we talked
about all these high availability
features now we have some new scheduling
challenges as well so you could run a a
cluster across multiple availability
zones already and by default the
scheduler will just put the containers
in the first free pod in the first free
node that it finds without much regard
to where things should be so you can
have some extra use cases so for
instance you have a legacy service
running on a VM in zone C
you want to run some parts which
particularly need to talk to that legacy
service I think you might like them to
be together because you want to minimize
and avoid that little bit of latency
that comes with talking in between zones
and and some small costs as well we
might be like ego and you might have a
special node pool with special hardware
for video encoding and you want your
pods to run in that notebook well now we
have extra control over that with
something called node affinity so in
this case we have our legacy service
running in zone C and we want to show
jewel APOD next to it and we can
configure that in something like this
now I know this looks like llaman on a
slide and lunch is nearly here but it's
a bit like poetry I think if you keep
saying required during scheduling
ignored during execution there's
something something wonderful if I have
that and I think if you if you think
about what that means it means that here
we've got something like a key in a
value so we're saying that our key is
our failure domain in this case a zone
and we want to our port to to be landing
in zone C here and we we actually
require that so that that is a strong
strong requirement we could also say
that we prefer during scheduling ignored
during execution and unlike node
selector we get these extra operators
including some exclusive operators that
would let us repel workloads from from
that particular key and some standard
some standard keys so we have failure
domains zone and region hostname and you
can have custom things also preemptable
SSDs that sort of thing so that gives us
some control them but there are other
use cases that may be no Definity
doesn't help you with so well so say you
have a front-end service and a back-end
service and you want them to land
together again to minimize latency
they're talking to each other all the
time but they're not actually in the
same part so these two processes ideally
are in the same availability zone as
well that's something that we call
north-south communication and you don't
want to have to say they have to be in
Zone B or Zone C you just want them to
be in the same availability
zone so that's something where you can
achieve with Interpol affinity here it
is again required during scheduling
ignored during execution so again we
have a topology key in this case we just
say that's the zone and we have an
operator which is in and we're saying
that our back end should land in the
same zone as our front end we could say
preferred during scheduling ignored
during execution and in this case we
could also say what happens at execution
is important as well so say something
changes in the cluster topology
everything everything could move around
so pods that were no longer in the right
place because something changed we would
move to another node now one more one
more quite tricky thing and that's
taints and toleration x' so imagine you
have some one one node which has got
some special hardware on it and two
regular nodes so here we've got three
nodes and one of them has a couple of
GPUs in it say for your use case you go
video encoding and here we've got a
regular pod which is just going to do
some sort of regular job it doesn't
particularly need a GPU and it comes
along and the clusters there and it just
gets sheduled in the first node that it
comes to and that just happens to be our
GPU node which is a shame because next
along comes the GPU pod so by that I
mean a pod that's going to do some work
that that would really benefit from
having access to that GPU but we could
have this scenario now where we've
already scheduled something on our GPU
node and it's it's basically full up
there's no extra capacity there so
either this GPU workload won't get
scheduled or or it'll have to go
somewhere else and effectively our GPU
are expensive GPU hardware is wasted
well we can solve that with something
called tints and Toleration x' so this
is quite simple really
we can we can label our GPU node with
something called attaint so it's marked
that it has a GPU and we say we use this
expression prefer no schedule which just
means
it's going to repel everything that
comes it's wave so and saying I don't
want any pots unless when the GPU pod
comes along we've given it something
called a toleration so this pod can
tolerate running on a GPU node so we'll
get the happy case where the regular
part is not being charged or there
because it was repelled because it did
not have that toleration
but the toll that take the the pod with
the toleration for GPU the one that once
the GPU can take the slot and now we end
up in this happy scenario now imagine
because we say prefer no schedule
imagine the case where our regular pods
have already filled up all of the
available capacity and the only place
left to schedule something is on the pod
which as the GPU well that can happen
because of that preference so it's a
loose constraint so how many people in
the audience hold up your hand if you
heard of this concept of of an SRE a
site reliability engineer so that's
there's something we believe in a lot at
Google we literally wrote the book on
site reliability engineering it's a
major contribution we made to the to the
DevOps culture I would say well we want
to be your sre too so you go talked
about how Google takes care of managing
your control plane for you this takes
away a lot of the pain so routine ops
like stuff you have to do like handling
backups monitoring repairing the control
plane should something go and they go
wrong in the availability zone or
wherever it is that the physical
hardware in this case is container
engine so the availability zone we we
take care of keeping it healthy and we
can resize that control plane for larger
clusters and we aim to keep it running
for you all of the time and we also look
after the components on your note said
the kubernetes components so we we give
you things like logging with stackdriver
integrated with stack driver monitoring
metrics we pre install the components
needed to act as a back-end for our
global load balancer and now with 1.6 we
can manage your nodes too so we can
handle operating system updates
security patches kubernetes upgrades
seamlessly and if there's a problem it
is a problem with the kernel of a VM or
it's out of memory or something else is
detected we can also drain the pods that
are running on there if we can and
restart that node and bring up another
one to replace it so you don't have to
think about that kind of thing and so
that you can keep track of all of that
we have a full audit trail so you can
tell whether it was someone from your
team or the robot that took those
actions on your behalf so what's next
well in 1.7 we've got another release
coming they come every three months and
they're pretty much bang on time all of
the time we're gonna have better support
for GPUs which is now a feature you can
have on one Google compute engine
content container engine we're going to
do more to keep your secrets secret so
you can integrate with something like
Google's certificate manager or hashey
curve how she call vault to distill the
secrets that your services might use to
talk to each other or things in the
outside world we're going to have IP
virtual switch load balancing so that's
a bit faster than the existing built-in
load balancing using IP tables we're
going to make it easier for add-ons to
integrate with the core Cuban ATS API
and it's going to be possible to upgrade
the components of kubernetes on a
running classroom more easily and this
is the thing Matt mentioned it earlier
the thing thing that I'm most excited
about at the moment because I'm really
interested in micro services and there
are still challenges with micro services
so you've you hear the story all the
time about how people are breaking their
monoliths down into into into micro
services but it it does bring some
complexity most successful micro service
stories started in that way breaking
down some existing thing into a monolith
and everyone's or every developer at
least is probably familiar with dealing
with concerns like how do I handle an
HTTP failure how do I do
HTTP retries and exponential back-off
and that kind of thing
perhaps in five languages how do I
handle rate limiting or
internal load balancing and between my
services how do those services really
discover each other people are
introduced introducing all sorts of
additional frameworks for service
discovery how do i why should my
application have to think about its own
encryption when that could just be
handled by something at the network
level a service mesh and SDO brings you
all of those things so it's something
that's completely open-source it's been
designed to run on any platform any
environment but first of all it's
running on kubernetes it's an effort
from the community so Google are
obviously involved IBM and lyft brought
their invoice proxy which is a super
fast it was already open source C++
layer 7 proxy load balancer which
automatically gets injected next to your
pods except the traffic and can handle
all kinds of great things like the
things I mentioned before even canary
releasing or directing traffic that's
activated that comes from a particular
person to a particular back-end or
version of your service and you can try
it out today so I think with just a
couple of commands you could install it
in a kubernetes faster running locally
or on container engine and there are
some great tutorials on the website if
you go to the tasks there you can you
can get running with canary releasing
and user specific sort of a/b testing
and things like that more or less
straight away so please have a look at
sto dot IO and if you if you're not
already playing with the communities
cluster you can do that on your laptop
so you could try all of the features
I've talked about today by installing
mini cube which is represented by the
first logo it's one command to install
it on a laptop and you can you have a
running single node obviously cluster or
you could take advantage of Google
container engine and our free pricing
tier so you get $300 a month and you
could run a multi node cluster for quite
a while on Google container engine and
try out all of these things like multi
availability zones and have a look at
this do because I think is really cool
I'll be down here at the front
immediately afterwards and then out in
the hall so if you have any questions
please just come up to me and ask and
thank you very much
you